committee will come to order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare recesses of the
committee at any time we welcome
everyone to today's hearing an oversight
of the report by special counsel robert
muller the third former White House
Counsel
Donald Magan the second I will now
recognize myself for an opening
statement more than a year ago White
House Counsel done began sat for the
first of several interviews with Special
Counsel Robert Muller over the course of
those interviews he described how the
president directed him to have the
special counsel fired he described how
the president ordered him to lie about
it
he describes several other obstructive
incidents outlined in the special
counsels report the president in
contrast refused to be interviewed by
the special counsel or even to answer
written questions about his attempts to
obstruct the investigation instead to
address the allegations spelled up I
missed him again and outlined in the
report
president Trump relied on his preferred
mode of communication he took to Twitter
to call mr. McGann a liar his lawyers
went on cable television
to do the same to call mr. McGann a liar
there are reports of the president and
his lieutenants exerting other kinds of
pressure on mr. McGann in short the
president took it upon himself to
intimidate a witness who has a legal
obligation to be here today this conduct
is not remotely acceptable the White
House asserts that mr. McGann does not
have to appear today because he is
entitled to quote absolute immunity
unquote from our subpoenas we know this
we know this argument is wrong of course
because the executive branch has tried
this approach before in 2007 President
George Bush attempted to invoke a
similarly
brought an unjustified assertion of
executive privilege and asked his former
counsel Harriet Miers to ignore a
subpoena issued by this committee MS
Meyers also did not appear at her
scheduled hearing Judge John Bates was
appointed by President Bush slapped down
that argument fairly quickly quote the
executive cannot identify a single
judicial opinion that recognizes
absolute immunity for senior
presidential advisors in this or any
other context that simple yet critical
fact bears repeating the asserted
absolute immunity claim here is entirely
unsupported by the case law close quote
from the judicial decision in other
words when this committee issues a
subpoena even to a senior presidential
advisor the witness must show up our
subpoenas are not optional mr. McGann
has a legal obligation to be here for
this scheduled appearance if he does not
immediately correct his mistake this
committee will have no choice but to
enforce the subpoena against him mr.
McGann did not appear today because the
president prevented it just as the
president has said the that he would
quote fight all subpoenas close quote
issued by Congress as part of his
broader efforts to cover up his
misconduct this stonewalling makes it
all the more important to highlight some
of the incidents that mr. McGann is said
to have witnessed let me recount some of
them we know that the president directed
missed them again to prevent then
attorney General Sessions from accusing
himself from overseeing the
investigation into Russian election
interference on March 3rd 2017
shortly after Attorney General Jeff
Sessions did recuse himself from the
Russian investigation the president
summoned mr. McGann to the Oval Office
according to the Muller report quote the
president opened the conversation by
saying I don't have a lawyer
unquote the president told mr. McGann
that he wished that Roy Cohn was his
attorney instead or a cone of course is
known principally as the chief architect
of the army McCarthy hearings that
destroyed so many lives back in 1954 an
actual political witch-hunt not the
imaginary kind - the president - cries
mr. Cohn served as president Trump's
lawyer for a long time defending the
president against federal discrimination
suits before he that is Mr McGowan was
ultimately disbarred for unethical
practices in 1986 mr. McGann refused to
follow blindly into unethical behavior
mr. McGann told the president that the
Department of Justice ethics officials
had weighed in and that mr. sessions
would not unruhe cues himself and he
advised the president not to have any
contact with mr. sessions on the matter
days later the president did exactly the
opposite he summoned missed them again
and mr. sessions tomorrow Lago where the
president again quote expressed his
anger unquote he said he wanted mr.
sessions to act as his fixer he said he
wanted mr. sessions to undo his recusal
and to limit the scope of the
investigation but mr. sessions too
refused the president's orders On June
17 2017 the president took his
displeasure a step further he called mr.
McGann at home and directed him to order
rod Rosenstein to fire
Robert Muller Muller has to go the
president barked call me back when you
do it once again mr. McGann refused this
time mr. McGann felt the president's
behavior was so inappropriate that he
said he would rather resign than trigger
a constitutional crisis in early 2018
after press reports described the
president's attempt to force mr. McGann
to remove the special counsel on his
behalf the president repeated his
pattern he summoned mr. McGann through
his office and he got angry whoa this
story doesn't look good you need to
correct this
you're the White House Counsel close
quote president Trump told mr. McGann
what about these notes
why do you take notes the president said
to mr. McGann enquiring my mr. McGann
had documented their conversation
the president then told mr. McGann to
tell the American people something that
was not true
he asked him to deny those reports
publicly mr. McGann again refused the
president's order he refused the
president's ordered to lie to the
American people on the president's
behalf six months later the president
announced that mr. McGann would be
leaving the White House the special
counsel found mr. McGann to be quote a
credible witness with no motive to lie
or exaggerate given the position he held
in the White House Bo's quote that's
from the Muller report the special
counsel also found the following quote
substantial evidence indicates that by
June 17 2017 the president knew his
conduct was under investigation by a
federal prosecutor who could present any
evidence of federal crimes to a grand
jury
substantial evidence indicates that the
president's attempts to remove the
special counsel were linked to the
special counsels oversight of
investigations that involved the
president's conduct and most immediately
to reports that the president was being
investigated for potential obstruction
of justice substantial evidence
indicates of these are all quotes from
the report substantial evidence
indicates that in repeatedly urging
McGann to dispute that he was ordered to
have the special counsel terminated the
president acted for the purpose of
influencing McGann's account in order to
deflect or prevent further scrutiny of
the president's conduct towards the
investigation substantial evidence
indicates that the president's efforts
to have sessions limit the scope of the
special counsels investigation to future
election interference was intended to
prevent further investigative scrutiny
of the president and his campaigns of
conduct I close quote those were all
quotes from the special counsels report
I believe that each of these incidents
documented in detail in the Mali report
constitutes a crime but for the
Department of Justice's policy of
refusing to indict any sitting president
I believe the president would have been
indicted and charged with these crimes I
am not alone in this belief over 900
former federal prosecutors from across
the political spectrum whose job was to
determine when the elements of the crime
have been satisfied have stated have
agreed that the president committed
crimes that would have been charged if
he were not the sitting president and I
believe that the president's conduct
since the report was released with
respect to mr. McGann's testimony and
other information we have sought has
carried this a pattern of obstruction
and cover-up well beyond the four
corners of the Muller report the
president has declared out loud his
intention to cover-up this misconduct he
told mr. McGann to commit crimes in his
behalf he told mr. McGann to lie about
it after the report came out the
president claimed that mr. McGann lied
to the special counsel about what
happened then he directed mr. McGann not
to come here today so that the public
would not hear his testimony and so that
we could not question him president
Trump may think he can hide behind his
lawyers as he launches a series of
baseless legal arguments designed to
obstruct our work he cannot think these
legal arguments will prevail in court
but he can think he can slow us down
and run out the clock on the American
people let me be clear this committee
will hear mr. McGann's testimony even if
we have to go to court to secure it we
will not allow the president to prevent
the American people from hearing from
this witness we will not allow the
president to block congressional
subpoenas putting himself and his allies
above the law we will not allow the
President to stop this investigation and
nothing in these unjustified and
unjustifiable legal at
tax will stop us from pressing forward
with our work on behalf of the American
people we will hold this president
accountable one way or the other it is
now my pleasure to recognize the ranking
member the Judiciary Committee the
gentleman from Georgia mr. Collins for
his opening statement
Thank You mr. chairman thank you for all
that have gathered here again here we go
again the theater is open and the
summations are coming in in fact right
now we're again running over the norms
of congressional oversight we're dabbing
at the edges of program roughshod on the
Constitution asking for things that we
don't but I am glad about one thing I'm
glad that the Chairman read into the
record today the model report I'm glad
that he quoted as he said this is a
quote directly from the motor part I
just wished my chairman to actually go
read the rest of it that he has been
offered to read which he has chose not
to read but he didn't leave out one
thing he left out something in their
motor report from just now he read them
against testimony beautifully did
everything well but he left out what he
doesn't want to have to come back to and
the frustrating thing that has brought
us here again and again and again and
that is the conclusions there was no
collusion
there was no obstruction charge there's
nothing here
after two years of doing this we can
read it in you can talk about how you
don't like it you can talk about what
you would like to ask but at the end of
the day it's interesting we'll read in
the quotes that make the headlines and
we're also going to read in the bottom
line of what was actually concluded so
the Democrats are here trying again the
mower report concluded there was no
collusion no obstruction because the
report failed to provide damning
information against the president the
majority claims we need to dig deeper
deeper than the two years of
investigation conducted by what is
considered a prosecutorial dream-team
because that probe ended without
criminal charges against the president
or his family the special counsel closed
up shop without giving Democrats
anything to deliver to their base now
the Democrats are trying desperately to
make something out of nothing which is
why the chairman has again haphazardly
subpoenaed today's witnesses that move
though is actually ensured the witness
will not testify you know this is
becoming a pattern the Chairman knew
this
when he sent the subpoena last month but
instead of inviting the witness to
testify voluntarily and working with
McGann's counsel to find mutual
agreeable time and scope for the
testimony the Chairman rushed to
maximize headlines by sub issuing a
subpoena that subpoena was the third in
just four months more subpoenas than the
prior chairman issued in six years the
chairman has several ways out here he
took none of them the Chairman could
have invited the witness to testify
voluntarily that was the practice in the
1990s when the White House counsel
testified before Congress but the
chairman did not do that instead he
launched a subpoena at the witness
without any consultation or follow up
with the witnesses lawyer the Chairman
could have invited the witness to
testify behind closed doors but that
would have been politically expedient
and you wouldn't been here and the show
would not have been as exciting a closed
door conversation would not have
generated those headlines and everything
that we're looking at today even
gaveling in today's hearing without a
witness's theatrical the cameras love a
spectacle and will majority loves the
chance to ran against the administration
I just am glad today to see that we
don't have chicken on the dice the
Chairman orchestrated today's
confrontation when he could have avoided
it because he's more interested than the
fight in fact finding take the molar
report which we've already heard quoted
from more than 99% of the Justice
Department has offered to the chairman
for an entire month the Chairman is
fused to take a look at it the Attorney
General who volunteered volunteered to
testify before the committee the
Chairman changed the rules for the first
time the committee's 200 year history
thus blocking general Barr from
testifying I cannot emphasize this
enough the track record demonstrated he
does not actually want information he
wants the fight but not the truth the
closer he actually comes to obtaining
information the further we run from it
the Democrats claimed the need today's
investigative witness to investigate
obstruction of justice but that
investigation was already done
Robert Muller spent two years running it
and then closed it we're not a
prosecutorial body but a legislative
body that does have valid congressional
oversight but let's talk about that
model report for just a second it's
really interesting to me that the molar
report was actually within 24 hours of
coming out the chairman and the majority
subpoenaed for all the documents in fact
we have a legal subpoena that acts the
Attorney General to provide documents he
cannot legally provide that's been
covered in this committee
for the last two weeks exhaustively and
even the panel that was with us last
week agreed that the subpoena asked the
Attorney General to do something illegal
by exposing 6e information that was his
own witnesses said that last week but
you know what's interesting to me is
that we subpoenaed the documents we
subpoenaed that we won't underline dogs
we explained it's nothing we can't get
but you know the one thing that we seem
to avoid is mr. Muller himself the one
who wrote it
we've asked since April about mr. Muller
coming but every time we seem to get
closer mother mother just gets pushed on
a little bit hasn't seen the subpoena
here and this is what's really amazing
we'll get back to subpoenas in a moment
but just think about that you wanted the
work of the author but you don't want to
talk to the author keep that penned for
just a moment when we look at this 99%
of the information is at the Democrats
fingertips and it's a Muller report
Attorneys General offered to speaker
Pelosi chairman Allen and others have
seen it but they refused so don't be
fooled majority wants to fight they want
the drama he does not actually want the
information he claims to be seeking
after the administration made volumes of
information available this committee the
Chairman issued over broad subpoenas and
now harangues the administration for
being unable to comply with those
subpoenas in fact this is Democrats are
engaging not engaging an accommodation
process abruptly cutting off negotiation
is rejecting olive branches by the
administration this is where I want to
come back to something our Chairman just
said a moment ago his quote was in his
opening statements that our subpoenas
are not optional well we found out a lot
about subpoenas over the last month or
so in this committee I found out their
subpoenas maybe now are not optional
let's add to the list subpoenas are also
a discussion starter a subpoena is to
give us better standing in court not my
quotes the Chairman's quotes so what is
it is a subpoena the legal document that
we've talked about all along here in the
forceful document that all attorneys in
this country actually use or is it a
discussion starter is it to help our
standing in court or is it we don't want
it ignored at this time it is amazing to
me that the accommodation process and we
talk about the comedian the chairman
forcefully talk about our oversight I
agree with the chairman on this point
this committee and all committees in
Congress have oversight responsibilities
but it is also the sacred
responsibilities of the Chairman and
geordie to use it properly and to not
headlong rush into subpoenas when you
don't get to what you want that's always
seen in five months here when we don't
get what we want we subpoena the first
one was the acting Attorney General we
subpoenaed and then we backed off we
cave then everything else has become a
race to get a headline the accommodation
process not happening the accommodation
process never here so don't be fooled
you may have come morning you may have
an opinion that says everything is wrong
today with the motor report and the
president is guilty but don't undercut
congressional oversight because you
can't wait that's the problem we have
right now and so the question is are we
tearing at the fabric of congressional
oversight
it was really interesting to hear some
of that last week when you have a
committee that has issued subpoenas that
asked the Attorney General to do
something illegal when you have
subpoenas when no accommodation process
has been put in place when you have
contempt issues that have been apart
with no process and no time going
through I just submit to you this
whatever your opinion on the motor
report great glad you have it but you
didn't get it here today and you're not
getting it from this committee because
this committee undoubtedly doesn't like
the author I want to talk to the author
of the report they just want to talk
about the report and make innuendo and
attack the president at the middle of
the day when this committee who has
charge of immigration who has charge of
intellectual property who we've touched
none of with a crisis at the border we
have an admission that the economy is
good jobs are happening unemployment is
his lowest rate I guess at the end of
the day we can't find something that the
mower report lets them hang there I word
impeachment on which they can't even
agree on because the president is
continuing to do his job and we're here
again with the circus in full bars with
that I yield back mr. chairman mr.
chairman mr. chairman
Thank You mr. Collins who see
circulation strike last word
the gentleman from
motion is made to adjourn well chairman
mr. chairman motion to adjourn is not
debatable
all in favor opposed no recording move
recorded vote the clerk will call the
roll
on the motion to adjourn give the clerk
mr. Nadler aye
mr. Nadler boots I miss Lofgren miss
Lofgren votes
I miss Jackson Lee miss Jackson Lee
votes aye mr. Cohen mr. Cohen votes aye
mr. johnson of georgia mr. johnson of
georgia votes aye mr. Deutsch miss bass
miss bass votes aye mr. Richmond mr.
Richmond votes aye mr. Jeffries mr.
Cicilline mr. Cicilline votes aye
mr. swallow mr. Liu mr. Liu votes aye
mr. Raskin mr. Raskin votes aye miss
jayapal miss jayapal votes
I miss Demings miss Demings votes aye
mr. Cariah
mr. Correia votes aye miss Scanlon
I miss Scanlon votes I miss Garcia I
miss Garcia votes aye mr. [ __ ] mr.
[ __ ] boats I miss Macbeth I miss make
bath votes aye mr. Stanton Oh mr.
Stanton votes I miss Dean I miss Dean
votes I misma carcel Powell misma carcel
Powell votes
I miss Escobar I miss Escobar votes aye
mr. Collins mr. Collins votes no mr.
Sensenbrenner
mr. Chabot no and this is disgraceful
mr. Chabot votes no mr. Gohmert mr.
Gohmert votes no mr. Jordan mr. Jordan
votes no mr. buck mr. buck votes no mr.
Ratcliffe mr. Ratcliffe votes no mr. oby
mr. gates
mr. gates votes no mr. Johnson of
Louisiana mr. Johnson of Louisiana votes
no mr. BIG's mr. McLintock mr. McLintock
votes no mr. Skell
mr. russian dollar mr. eshton thaller
votes no mr. Klein mr. Klein votes no
mr. Armstrong mr. Armstrong votes no mr.
steuby mr. Stevie votes No anyone who
wishes to vote who hasn't voted
local report
mr. chairman there are 21 eyes and 13
nose 21 eyes the 13 nose the motion to
adjourn is adopted and the hearing is
adjourned